today on drew
get the story behind the scenes
tell her to unmute
can you hear us
of season one surprises
the zag was all david's idea and we
reveal our very first celebrity guest
and she is a very good friend
it all starts now
[Music]
please welcome drew barrymore
hi everybody welcome the season two
premiere of the drew barrymore show is
less than a week away september 13th
check your local listings or go to the
drewberrymoreshow.com
go to show finder type in your zip code
and boom you'll find out right away i
couldn't be more excited we're kicking
things off with a huge la premiere i'm
going back to the town that made me for
a whole week of hollywood shows because
there's no place like home
and then i'm returning to my new home
here in new york for another week of new
york city premier shows the week of
september 20th it's 10 days of
celebrating our roots and we'll be
highlighting hometowns all across the
country maybe even yours
go ahead back to the website
drewberrymartial.com
and let us know
why your hometown is special to you
but before we get to all of that we've
got this great roundup of our favorite
moments from season one with some bonus
content a little behind-the-scenes
commentary from me on what really went
down
so let's kick it off with a moment that
will stay with me forever
my producers and the whole team
planned a birthday show for me and i
wasn't in on one detail i asked please
don't tell me anything i i i don't want
to know i i don't think you're going to
do anything but whatever you do i'll
just you know not know and then all of a
sudden there were surprises and
gosh
you wouldn't even believe who showed up
i didn't even know
if there would be anyone here
but guess who came
david letterman
someone who is very much
inextricably linked in my history and he
came in studio in person during the
pandemic so it meant all the more
and he wished me happy birthday and
birthdays are kind of a thing between
him and i
anyway uh take a look
i'm gonna give you some clues okay let's
see how you would do
he would be
on your top 10 list of guests i think
you'd want at any party
you once
surprised him on his birthday
oh my god and his stupid human trick
david being one of the greatest
television hosts of all time do you know
who this might be i know exactly who it
is who is it david letterman
let us welcome
david letterman hi dave
everybody
hi drew
happy birthday
savannah hello how are you hi
she's dying she can't believe it oh my
gosh
i'm having a great time catching my
breath i can hear you
damn
i can't i can't hear her oh sh is there
a filter oh wait do you have a filter on
i can't tell her to unmute
are you zooming dave what's like yeah
are you good at technology i'm not a cat
that is everything i'm sorry i can't
hear her oh you look like a fine can you
hear me okay it's the thought that
counts yeah we can hear you we hear you
can you hear us
we get it
forget that can you believe i mean
that's so sweet of him to do that i know
when was the last time you actually saw
it i feel the same way he does about
zoom yeah um especially when my
daughters crash at i
[Music]
[Applause]
know everybody
[Applause]
how are you hi savannah hi james how are
you
hi
you look wonderful
nice to see you happy birthday
[Music]
what do you think
here sit down
oh my
i'm
gonna need the tissues yeah i'm so
grateful that you came here let me tell
you something you know that uh little
trick with the computer and stuff that
zoomer thing that was my idea that was
good you still got it oh thank you it
was really effective and i really
thought i was like okay yeah you know
dave i get it too
um no are you you're actually crying oh
that breaks my heart god bless you
i'm i'm i'm so grateful that you are
showing up well i i i can't i can't
thank you enough for everything and the
friendship that you demonstrated for us
when we were uh on the show and it meant
a great deal then and this means a great
deal as well happy happy birthday and
thank you thank you for or did i invite
myself i don't know how this happened
you're this you're kind of the guest of
honor next to drew but wait wait four
years actually crying she's crying she's
shocked i told her she really thought
she might know it i love you i love you
as well okay wait hold on this is so
weird it's drew's birthday
i'm savannah guthrie i'm here to
celebrate drew oh just david letterman
swinging by to shock drew i don't think
surprise is the word i think it's shock
and i kept saying she has to know this
woman is a seasoned show business
veteran
in front of the camera behind the camera
in her office anywhere you want to put
her she has to know this is going on and
and then you come out here and you're
crying and that was so touching and very
sweet of you thank you i'm just so
honored that you showed up oh please i
mean it because
um i feel even weird saying up for me
i'm just so happy to see you as an old
friend it's been a long time i i know
it's not my show to produce but how
great would this be
if it was really a surprise for somebody
guthrie
ladies and gentlemen
and
you know
in fact
i think we should uh roll a certain clip
get off the furniture
what is going on would you like me to do
a dance for you
what
hi paul
okay
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness that happened
[Applause]
dave do you remember that anything about
that yeah i'll tell you honestly uh
i used to watch old movies
blackboard jungle glenn ford and what
happens is the juvenile delinquent
teenagers take over the classroom and
they're up on glen ford's desk and
they're going to beat him up and so
drew is there
i love the high
and then and then she climbs up on the
desk and i i thought to myself oh no
i've lost control of the class
and and then my next thought was i think
i think i'm probably going to get kicked
and then everything changed you know
like in the wizard of oz when it goes
from black and white to color
that's what it was like i had
no plan
of doing that it was one of those
moments in my life where i felt like
a magnet was pulling me uh and it was
all very playful and well intended
and i just had no idea where it was
going and i almost was like should i be
embarrassed did i do something bad am i
in trouble and i knew in that moment
that with one turn you could have gone
why did you do that what's what's wrong
with you
and instead
you
had that smile
and you said to everyone this moment is
okay
[Laughter]
oh my god that was the moment oh my god
i hope that i can have a good man dave
is right now and just let something
innocent and spontaneous be innocent and
spontaneous well i recognized it
immediately as being unique
it had
it had not happened prior to me has not
happened since to me
and later i was thinking
oh geez now what if she goes and does
this on leno's show
then i'll really be upset
well with all dudes
it was kind of a connection for us
throughout our
the rest of our existence here you
compelled me in a moment to take a risk
and you allowed it to be paid off with
kindness and reciprocity and goodness
and humor which is my ultimate honestly
i think that's the greatest award and
reward that people can give each other
later we were of course married
we went to a church last step got
married look at me i'm like i think
you're so cute yeah
i did i i've had a crush on you forever
we were happy for another 20 minutes
yeah that's right and like normal
marriage drew was on your show 20 times
that's 20 times
remarkable well again yes absolutely and
and this is why
um all credit to you because in the
world of show business you have you have
two things you have show business
friendships which are not really
friendships and then you have actual
friendships and i considered
our relationship to be a true friendship
thank you i um
i was not there for shock value i was
there to share a moment with you that
took on a little bit of a life of its
own but my heart was so well intended
towards you
now let's talk about the the
circumstance now are you enjoying this
part of your life yeah as hard and
challenging as it is
um
i just feel like when i wake up in the
morning i wake up to savannah
and gail i go to sleep to people like
you and you know i think of a jimmy
fallon who's like family
and
you guys are who
jumpstart and close out our days and
that's why i felt so privileged to step
into a role that has been so
important to me as a citizen and a human
being walking around
you are literally telling people it's
okay to start their day here's how it's
going to go here's some optimism here's
some news and revision and you would say
you got through the day
i'm going to put you to bed
congratulations right now you're allowed
to live
this is a great way for you to look at
it because it's true the landscape
in the early morning uh middle of the
day or whenever we see you uh several
other people have helped along the way
have been very beneficial oprah was
fantastic so dave do you like being a
guest no no i'm very uncomfortable about
it although i'm very pleased about the
zoomer thing and i mentioned that was my
idea it was a good it worked yeah uh no
because i have nothing let me tell you
something do i can i talk a lot of
places don't want me to talk
out here it's interesting about life
you you learn things over that you
already learned and then you you forget
because
you're drawn toward the mundane
so you you can't be sucked into the the
reality the drama and the ugliness that
can be provided by life so you're drawn
toward the mundane and you learn these
lessons again and again and because of
the pandemic
you know people who have had it and
perhaps died i know people who have died
same same with all of us we're looking
at a half a million people i don't know
how many wars that is but a half a
million
stunning that we're living with every
day so i think
uh humanity is temporary
and we all know that and because it's
temporary
we need each other we more more than
ever when you realize it's temporary
need each other so i'm trying to be
outgoing and pleasant and helpful
whenever i can i always talk about
both of your shows as such like
my training ground my inspiration what i
needed in
life when i would see you out in your
trench coat man in the field i
i love you both so much
i honestly live to make you proud i mean
that with all of my heart
i can't believe i get to call you guys
my friends
is she gonna be all right
we love you so much and you know what
drew i gotta say thank you for bringing
us together i never got to meet dave
letterman savannah guthrie i said oh
yeah i know savannah and i realized no
we never did no but we're probably going
to text all the time now or zoom oh yeah
yeah you saw how much trouble i had with
the zoomer dave thank you so much this
was a great way to kick off the party
this was awesome
our producer cat kohler confirmed that
the zoom gag was all david's idea i mean
i love that i love that he was in on the
joke and coming up with little fun
details on this special day
what a dream come true we'll be right
back
[Music]
take a deep dive into the best of season
one i'm so in awe that we're all still
so close we've experienced everything
together and we gear up for our
star-studded two-week premiere event in
my original hometown of hollywood
i grew up here in los angeles i love it
here it all starts monday
on the next true barrymore show
welcome back right now i want to
highlight a friend of the show a member
of the drew's crew who helped us create
beautiful spaces for some very wonderful
people throughout season one call him
alumni here's the best of celebrity
interior designer
mikael welsh
please welcome someone i'm such a fan of
design expert and very good friend of
the show masterful artiste mikael welch
well hello
what i've created for you two ladies are
two separate twin beds now you needed a
headboard didn't want to break the bank
so there's an easy solution for this
i've done a painted headboard and then
you just layer everything up with a
bunch of pillows and you can complete
this project for less than thirty
dollars it's
so
brilliant macau the girls really needed
some additional storage right and so
i've given them a new dresser and then i
just did a simple mirror just to kind of
balance things off and you cannot miss
this girl right here i mean the pompous
grass faux chandelier is the star of the
show christelle are those happy tears
macau your client is happy i gave you
these cute little planters right here
and it just allows you an opportunity to
bring all of those you know fresh
greenery moments and to actually display
them you know oftentimes we just push
greenery into a corner but it's like no
like get it up off the floor let us see
it it's a very zen like moment another
thing i want to point out that i was
really inspired by mikael in your
choices was that you echoed
the window treatment
to the closet what we were able to do
was to put drapes on the outside of the
closet and what that does it does a
couple of things so first it kind of
separates the space so it doesn't feel
as cluttered but then it's giving you
that optical illusion so you kind of
feel like you're in a much bigger space
it's super smart well natalie and
christelle what do you think of the room
i we love the room it's amazing i like
the closet and the beds look so this is
like amazing yeah you're finally in our
perfect group
thank you thank you so much
i'm super excited to show you your new
room i wish i could give you a hug i
know i can't i'm a hugger but i know i
can't michael i'm really excited to
learn from you and how you approached
this room
and gloria's closet okay so gloria i
think the biggest solution for you was
to add an oversized wardrobe which we've
done here honey we have storage and
storage and more storage so if you see
here we have hanging bars so you can get
all of your longer hanging amazing order
and then check this out we've got all of
these rollout bins so you know how you
have like your t-shirts sometimes you
roll them up like you can put jeans
t-shirts everything and you look like a
bling type of girl so i know bling bling
bling yeah you're into jewelry so we've
even got you jewelry
amazing so now everything's 12 of them
this is a lot of bling i gotta control
it all here
check this out
that's beautiful i
and then last but not least uh over here
we gave you some double hang so you can
amazing lots of clothes you have lots
and lots and lots of storage over here
and then did you personalize the handles
i did i did it
it looked good so we were putting the
design together and i had just like a
pretty ottoman and drew was like no like
she needs to like have some function so
drew said she wanted a storage ottoman
love it so now
you can have extra storage if your
husband gets on your nerves you can put
him in there too so listen you're
covered i'm gonna lock my door you put
padlock on the front once it looks
beautiful because nobody's coming in
it's beautiful michael you're beautiful
so amazing absolutely it's like a dream
come true thank you so much thank you
i'm glad you liked it
i cannot wait till our next project
oh my god you're in my mouth how does it
oh
i painted it you did that yourself no
girl i was about to be really impressed
i know
we had a little situation with the toys
i had to donate them um i'm joking oh my
god
oh my god i love what mikael did i don't
think this is a design by drew this is
straight up a design by mckeld
i cannot wait to see what mikael does in
season two and i'll be right there by
his side as design is my happy place and
we'll be right back with more of our
favorite moments for you right after
this
[Music]
we're back to bring you more
[Music]
the new season of drew premieres
september 13th
food i love eating it talking about it
watching it on tv here is some delicious
kitchen inspiration
hi drew thanks for having me back on the
show today i'm going to show you how to
tackle
steak it's always better to season your
steak with salt ahead of time a few
hours is fine but overnight is ideal
this will allow the salt to penetrate
all the way through to the center of the
steak set this on a wire rack and place
it in your fridge uncovered for airflow
you got an instant pot they all come
with this little rack how do you know
when your pan is hot enough with this
hat you will forever get a good sear on
your steak every single time drop a
teaspoon of water into your pan and when
it looks like team 1000 out of
terminator it means your pan is ready
this is called the leidenfrost effect
and if your water sticks and bubbles out
means your pan is too cold and it's not
ready for new york strips i like to add
zero oil fat side down first render out
that fat and then sear both sides for
about two minutes per side when you're
ready to butter base turn down the heat
to low because butter burns at high
temperatures which can leave burnt
bitter taste onto the steak and butter
absolutely loves aromatics like thyme
and garlic because they're good buddies
and they infuse really really well
together a digital thermometer is a must
always remove the steak 10 degrees lower
than your desired doneness because the
steak will continue to cook even when
it's out of the pan cover and let it
rest resting allows the muscle proteins
to relax so it can retain more of its
own juices and flavor i like to make a
quick sauce using horseradish a mustard
salt and pepper i always cut my steaks
at a bias because it always makes for a
better meat fan and finally don't sleep
on the resting juices this is where the
magic is at now watch this move whoa
now you tell me if this will taste good
or not
and that's how you cook a steak
wow i'm in a delicious food coma just
for watching that
[Music]
welcome back
with everything going on in the world
these days we can't lose sight of the
fact that there are real heroes among us
that's right people who do good things
and on this show we like to shine a
light on those we call drew gooders and
one of my favorite was from season one
eighteen-year-old justin gavin from
brooklyn new york we formed a friendship
and we have a payoff for this one take a
look
he saw a burning car on the street
with a mother and her three children
inside
and without hesitation he risked his own
life to pull each one of them out of
that burning car
into safety
please welcome right here in the studio
justin gavin
i am really star struck to meet a real
life hero
i mean i wouldn't call myself a hero i
just thought i just thought i just did
what was right so i'm not gonna call
myself hero
but may i ask when you see that
what goes on inside of your head and
body is it a trajectory that just
happens are you thinking what what does
it feel like
um to me i feel like at that moment
it was no thinking like i just thought
what was right i knew if i was in that
situation i definitely want someone to
do exactly what i did
but
not all people was like that but i'm
just glad i was there at the right place
at the right time
you really were so
what what were you you were just walking
down the street on your merry way
um
yeah i was i ended up running to
everyone and i just saw a bunch of cars
and they were just honking at horns and
it was yelling out the car was on fire
the cars were fired and i was clueless i
didn't know what was happening so i actu
i actually did see the car
after a while and i'm like oh get out
the car get out the car your car was on
fire and nobody was running towards the
car i was trying to do anything to help
out so i just ran to this car and do you
reach in at that point do you open doors
or what what are you doing um i told the
oldest which is nine years old to like
unbuckle her seatbelt a sibling seat
belt it was nine
four and one i believe then
it was all it was scary for me because i
didn't know what was gonna happen i
thought at that time i was actually
gonna lose my life and they were gonna
lose their life but if i did lose my
life i would lose my life trying to save
somebody else so it was
[Applause]
i mean
do you believe in angels
yeah i do i do a lot of people call me
an eg but i just feel like i just did
the right thing
you really are an angel and i i mean i
just i believe there are humans
masquerading as angels i believe that
there is capacity
in a human but to sit here and hear your
story i mean you are what i think people
need to believe in we need to believe in
angels in human form
i i i just okay so everyone ended up
okay yeah everybody ended okay to mom
at one point she couldn't really breathe
correctly but the um paramedics helped
out gave her more oxygen so she can
actually stop breathing correctly and
she was just grateful that i was there
the kids was grateful
um it was i was just happy that they
were all safe i'm glad that i was safe
i'm glad everybody
at that air in the area was safe nobody
really got home but i mean you saved an
entire family i i just i'm sorry i'm i'm
really i am just in awe of you and
um the mayor of um
waterbury connecticut um where this
happened when he heard what you did he
wanted to do something for you so he
asked me to give you this proclamation
of the town
in honor of your bravery
um
and that's not all when we heard um that
you had a particular favorite basketball
player he also heard what you did and he
had this to say it's carmelo anthony
what
yo justin
it's carmelo anthony here bruh i heard
about your story man i want to let you
know how inspiring and courageous you
are man you're a true true hero you've
inspired me man and i'm so inspired to
have someone like you
uh supporting me throughout my career
um i appreciate it more than you even
know
i also heard you're a sneaker head like
me so we're going to hook you up with
some joint brands uh merch as a small
thank you for the big things that you've
been doing man um
and that you continue to do so
you know i'll leave you with this um
you know just keep pushing man keep
persevering keep making your family
proud uh again thank you for what you
did and just know we all rooting for you
man and know you're going to continue to
do great things
peace
stay mellow
[Applause]
we also found out that you're a fan of
the brooklyn nets and they wanted to say
thank you too
so
so we have hooked you all up we're
getting you season passes go to all the
games the players are excited to meet
you
and really there's just not enough that
we can do here at the show there's no
way
to sort of monetize or match your act of
saving an entire family but we just
wanted to
start
in some way and everybody joined in and
we just are in awe of you honestly thank
you so much thank you justin
yeah you're gonna see justin back on our
show in season two
because we're both gonna get our geds
oh
i'm nervous we'll be right back
[Music]
welcome back in one of our very first
episodes i admitted something about
myself
i'm a stand for stains and on this show
stain removal isn't a chore it's an art
form
see what i mean in our very first stand
for stains segment
i have a secret obsession
and it is with stains no
in fact i stand
for stains and the reason i messed that
up is because stan is a new word to me
apparently it means stalker and fan it
was kind of originated by eminem so i'm
definitely going with it
so
i'm a stan for stains the bigger the
tougher the stickier the better i'm a
mom so this was like kind of perfect i
my passion works i love concocting the
perfect solutions products combinations
treats treatments methodologies tools
are very important process is important
so i asked some people to send me in
their stains and then i'm gonna help
them figure out how to fix it let's see
how this goes okay first
julia sent us a video take a look
hi drew my name is julia morales and i'm
from chicago illinois and i need your
help
girl you have no idea i
love to party i had a really great party
but a couple of friends of mine have
spilled some fruit punch
on my carpet and i'm supposed to be
moving and my landlord said he's going
to charge me if i don't get that stain
up i have no idea how to get this out
rue please please please please help me
okay first of all julia we both know
that that isn't juice
and second of all
if it's really wine i need to know that
because it takes a different method but
let's just pretend it's juice
here is everybody's first mistake in my
opinion if you get stuff in your carpet
do not leave it till the next day you
want to have it be wet because that's
how the absorption happens don't think
oh i'll attack that later you won't it's
set in at that point you can still fix
it make it a part of the party hey
i'm still grooving and talking but i'm
doing this at the same time okay
like
the fun doesn't have to stop i mean as
far as i'm concerned the fun just
started
but seriously like don't think that's a
next day project
i'm not a righteous person but i'm kind
of righteous about stains
don't push on it
lift absorb you want to gently tap a
very absorbent thing
when people go in and start doing this
i'm like
so this i am literally i am like it's
like a a a bunny's paw on cotton
you're gonna pat kind of like
you're the bunny going like hey
i want some of that like hey
then you can take a multitude of stain
removals so i'm going to take my trusty
draft
also
don't put a ton of stuff on a stain like
be gentle with it it's like
you know think baby bunny when it comes
to stains how are we looking
thank you this is important to me
i'm single
i live with my two children
and how i party and get off in my free
time is i
kill stains okay so if you have one i'm
interested all right i want to party
let's do this michael i understand you
have a stain
show me what you got
hey drew my name is michael redden i'm a
real estate agent from whippany new
jersey and
i love eating ice cream unfortunately
when i eat ice cream i get a little bit
into it and i wound up staining my
favorite white shirt with chocolate ice
cream i need to get this stain out i
don't know what to do drew i need some
help
listen it happens this is nothing
chocolate is nothing again this is why
yeah that's right the draft is coming
back out
all right now this time i'm gonna treat
the draft very differently i mean this
is like literally finding your soulmate
i'm not kidding
i love you
oh sherry
you set my soul on fire
that's what i do to my daughter olive
all the time it's from a tom and jerry
cartoon and she goes
mom
because you know i don't know about you
but i just live to embarrass my children
so i'm just using my fingertip
so at this point if you want you can
start to
gently again think bunny
so i'm trying to make this go a little
faster because we have a lot of other
things to accomplish today but i am in
my happy place right now
here's another tip
the fibers actually can work as an
abrasiveness so you can actually start
to rub it together
if you don't have a toothbrush handy
water in the bowl excellent okay
this is pure water oh it's warm too
all right now normally i would put this
under a big running faucet
wring it dry
and then present you with your shirt i
want you to find that chocolate god darn
it
that's right
that's right
bring me
your
stains i want the challenge
this is my happy place bring it on what
have you got for me
well maybe i need to go get a life but
you know what i don't care
i love stain removal i do stand for
stains
since that first stand for stain segment
aired we've removed spaghetti sauce
marshmallow stickiness grease barbecue
sauce popsicles green juice out of
michael strand's suit and so much more
and i can't wait to see what stains
we're gonna tackle
in season two
i won't have to wait long because it's
less than a week away
oh stays you better watch out don't go
anywhere there's more show up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back we're looking back on our
favorite moments from season one of the
drewberry marshall and just before the
break we saw me stand for some stains
well in this moment from last season i'm
standing for even more cleaning and
organizing solutions
it's for the fridge
and we had a mom whose tick tock video
of her organizing the snack drawer in
her fridge racked up over 26
million views
and i still follow her she changed my
life and game meet monica brady
tick-tock is a gold mine for the latest
trends and tricks and even that includes
cleaning
okay this is so exciting i can't wait
one woman racked up 26 million views for
hypnotic video of her cleaning and
restocking the snack drawer of her
fridge i could watch this all day long
no it's so brilliant she's a mom from
michigan who cleans and calms with every
tick tock video she posts and guess what
rassi what she's here i know
please welcome monica brady hi monika
hi
oh my gosh i'm i'm so excited to be here
with you guys
oh we feel the same way about you and
what an impressive um
thing that you've done monica procuring
millions and millions not like three
four or five i'm talking like 25 30
million people are watching your videos
why do you think that they're so
hypnotizing and people are so drawn to
that what's the secret
so
i just really feel like with asmr and
cleaning videos at least this is the
feedback that i've gotten from like my
followers
is they're really motivating for people
um like they'll be after dinner and
they'll be you know relaxing and
enjoying their meal and
and they're like oh i just came across
this tic tac and she's you know
organizing her fridge or she's cleaning
something and it just really motivates
my followers and they reach out to me
and they just love it and it just
motivates them and i just love producing
this kind of content for people because
of that well it motivated me i have to
say i watched your video and then i i
attacked my refrigerator um i really did
this weekend i and i like cleaned it and
turned all the labels forward because
you gave me refrigerator envy but for
people who think that they can't do that
where do we start
good question start small would be my
biggest piece of advice um and if
anybody's new and starting organization
i would really recommend um
just like mapping out your fridge like
where do you want the produce to go
where do you want the drinks to go where
do you want the snacks to go um just if
everything is right up front and just
easy to grab like the produce is washed
if you know how many drinks you have you
know what drinks you have
there's less likely to be waste in the
fridge and there's less likely to be
waste of food as well at least that's
how it is in our home that we've you
know it's everything gets eaten for the
most part yeah if you can see it you
don't waste it it makes sense right
right right now it's not just
refrigerators okay right you also went
viral for a little laundry hack tell us
about that it did so back um
beginning of covid actually
my husband and i redid our laundry space
and he put a shelf up above the um
washer and dryer and i put all you know
my laundry products up there and i was
like
this is really disappointing because the
laundry containers are ugly and um i
found these gorgeous glass um contain
glass jars they're actually like
beverage dispensers yeah you like you
would put lemonade or ice cream
i think they're actually advertised as
an iced tea dispenser um
and they're only six dollars i'm like oh
this is awesome
such a brilliant idea so you don't have
like neon jug on display you can have
this cute little thing and then one day
i just decided you know i'm like hey i'm
going to film this i feel like it's
something tic tac would like and it
completely blew up and that's where my
tic tac
platform started actually
well monica what i love about what
you're doing is that it's leading
functionality and tips and ways to
organize and make life prettier
i am so into what you're doing i'm so
happy that it's getting so much
recognition and i enjoy i understand
yeah i feel like i've learned so much
from you monica thanks for all these
tips oh my gosh i'm fangirling so much
because i love both of you and you guys
like literally watch my tic tacs i'm so
i'm so excited
monica come back and teach us more
seriously
oh anytime anytime
here are some pictures of my fridge
because she has literally changed my
life and i love it and she improved it
and that's what happens here on this
show and i love it it's what i call
hashtag fridge goals and we'll be right
back with some more inside info about
next season including our premiere show
guess
huh it's a good one don't move
[Music]
take a deep dive into the best of season
one i'm so in awe that we're all still
so close we've experienced everything
together and we gear up for our
star-studded two-week premiere event in
my original hometown of hollywood i grew
up here in los angeles i love it here it
all starts monday
on the next true barrymore show
welcome back we are less than a week
away from kicking off season two
of the drew barrymore show and our big
premier guest will be none other than
jennifer aniston
i mean
i could not be more excited to talk to
her
we actually were in a movie together
he's just not that into you and we have
a very good friend in common mr adam
sandler
and i gotta ask her about the morning
show because oh it is just one of my
favorites but everything she does is my
favorite she's jennifer aniston plus
while we're in my hometown of los
angeles i'll be taking you all on a tour
of the places that mean most to me
the house i grew up in
my very first apartment at 14.
and
i'm revisiting some other places that
might come as a surprise that i'm
actually revealing them but i mean them
to be an invitation to you
so that we can embrace everything that's
happened in our lives and be proud of
where it has brought us
it's happening all next week
on season two of the drew barrymore show
see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you